hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve distinct subsequences this
is another hard problem and this is
actually going to be solved with dynamic
programming it's very similar to some
other dynamic programming problems
involving subsequences particularly
longest common subsequence
which is a problem that i've solved on
this channel before so if you struggle
with this problem
i would recommend solving this one or
watching that video before
so we're given two strings s and t and
we want to return
the total number of distinct
subsequences
of s which equal t so basically what
we're doing is we're looking for
subsequences
of s that happen to match the entire
string t and if you don't remember what
a subsequence is
basically for let's say this string a
subsequence is just a subset
of some particular characters so
basically maybe we don't want to include
the b
we don't want to include the d so this
happens to be a subsequence ace right a
c e this one is not a subsequence
because it's not in the correct
order of these you can't change the
relative order of characters in the
subsequence
so we're given an example s and t so
basically these are both
rapid just spelled a little bit
differently right this one has an extra
b
in it so how many different sub
sequences of this string s
can we take that exactly match this
string t
well let's look character by character
so let's start at the first character of
this the first character of this
they exactly match each other right so
okay that's good so now we're going to
look at the sub problem right we found
these two match exactly now how many
different ways can these sub sequences
match each other
now how many ways can we get this string
how many sub sequences of it can we get
that match now the remainder of this
string
now we see again both of these
characters are a so so far they're
exactly matching each other that's good
and we get to a b these b's match each
other that's also good so so far we're
getting pretty close
to getting a subsequence of this to
exactly match this right we only have to
match three more characters
we see another b that's good but now we
see we're looking for an i right we need
an i
and a t so that we can create an exact
subsequence of this but
so far we have a b right so what are we
going to do in this case
so far what we've been doing is we've
been basically evaluating this we've
seen that at the i
pointer which is corresponding to the
string s and the j pointers
corresponding to string t
if the characters at those corresponding
positions match each other
we're basically just incrementing both
indices right because we're just trying
to match that string t
right so if both of the characters match
we can continue to move on right
so this is going to be the else
condition where we just got to right now
right we're looking at
b in the string s and i in the string t
right they don't match each other so
what we're going to do is we're going to
take
i and increment it by one we're going to
take the i pointer
and then shift it to this next character
over here
right why are we leaving j the same
though basically our j pointer is over
here and it's going to stay at this
character
why is it staying here because it's
required for us to
match every single character in string t
right that's what the goal of this
problem is we need all sub sequences
from s
that exactly match t so what we're doing
is so for now we're just saying this b
we're skipping it right now we're going
to look at the next character maybe
there's some ways that we can match the
remainder of this string
to this string okay so now our eye
pointer is at this
character i our j pointers at this
character i so in this case the
characters do match each other so what
are we going to do
similarly to what we did before we're
going to increment both indices by one
we can move to the next position so
we're at this character now in s we're
at this character now
in t once again these characters exactly
match each other
right so once again we're going to take
both pointers and shift them by one
now we get to a base case right both
strings are
empty so what are we going to return in
that case basically that tells us we
went through every single character in t
right and we matched every single
character now there's no characters
remaining right so what would the count
be in that case
how many subsequences of an empty string
can we match
to another empty string basically just
one right that's our base case we're
returning one now
but my question to you is hold on a
minute we're returning
one right so our result happens to be
one but in this problem description they
return to three
why is that how did they get three
different ways when our current
algorithm
that i've shown you these two conditions
only gave us a single one
so what did we end up missing well let's
take a look at their explanation over
here they say there's three different
ways why is that
well when you take a look at the b
characters right what we
said what we originally said is this b
is gonna match this b for sure and
that's the only way that we
did it but we and then basically we took
like over here you can see we took our
pointers and incremented them both by
one then we went to the next b
but that doesn't necessarily have to be
the case isn't it possible
just because these characters match
doesn't mean
we have to require them to match we can
say hey
let's just skip this b even though it
matches this b maybe there's another b
over here that can also match this b so
what i'm saying here is if these
characters match each other right if the
with this if condition we this is one
way we can do it but we can
also do another thing which is we can
take our i pointer
increment it by one and take our j
pointer and leave it the same
basically we're doing over here what we
did down here so in in
in this if case we're going to take both
of these results
basically counting the number of ways
that we can compute subsequences
with both of these and totaling them up
and that's what we're going to end up
returning
so what would happen if we ended up
skipping this b and then let's say we
took
this b and matched it with this previous
b right then what would we get well
then we'd get to these pointers right
and again we can say okay these b's are
now going to match each other
right and then these two i characters
are going to match each other and then
the t's are going to match each other so
that's an additional
one way that we could we could take a
subsequence of
s and turn it into t so that's another
way so far our total
is two so what's the third way that we
could do it well once again
we see that this b matches this b but it
doesn't have to be that way
in another way we could say okay these
b's match each other we're gonna now
skip the second b and we're gonna say
okay these two b's are gonna match each
other
so that is what the third way would be
and then of course we'd have our eyes
match and we'd have our t's match
so this covers exactly what we're going
to do if the characters match each other
and this is what we're going to do if
the characters don't match each other
we're going to do this recursively with
depth first search
or backtracking whatever you want to
call it and we we noticed that we're
probably going to be doing a lot of
repeated work meaning our
when we're calling that function we
might be passing in the same i
value and same j value into that
function so we're going to use a cache
so that we don't repeat the same work
twice and so how big is that cache going
to be well how many possible ways could
we call our depth first search function
we could call
an i value for basically the length of
our string
s and we could call a j value for the
length
of our string t so basically the number
of times we could call it is going to be
the length of both strings multiplied by
each other let's just say that's big
o of n times m so that's going to be the
memory as well
as the run time of this algorithm
because we're going to be caching it
i've solved a lot of dp problems with
the bottom up approach so this time i am
going to be using the recursive approach
which is top
down but there's one last thing i want
to cover before we jump into the code
let's look at two more base cases so
let's say our string s
had a single value a and let's say our
string t
was empty right so it's an empty string
how many subsequences of our string s
can we take that convert
exactly to t well only a single one
right so
basically if we just take this entire
string and just don't take any
characters from it that counts as a
subsequence
so this is gonna return one so basically
if our string t
is empty because we remember the
previous case where let's say
string t and string s were empty right
if they're both
empty strings then in that case we're
also ending up returning one so
basically the condition is if our string
t
is empty we return one as the base case
what about the opposite case where our
string
t is non-empty we have an a here but
maybe our string
s is empty now once again the question
is how many
subsequences of this string s can we
take that
exactly match the string t we're looking
to exactly match the string t
well since this is empty there's no
characters in it we can't possibly get
an
a from this so we can't possibly match
this a
character so therefore in this base case
we're going to end up returning
zero there's no subsequences of the
string s
that match string t so that's all that
we need to cover we have our base cases
handled and we have this logic that we
are going to be using
so now let's get into the code so as i
mentioned we are going to be using a
cache you could use a two-dimensional
array for this but i prefer using a hash
map or dictionary in python
because it just is a little bit easier
for me so we're going to be passing two
parameters i
and j which tell us the corresponding
positions of string s
and string t that we're currently at we
know that one base case is if
j has reached the end of the string that
means
string t is empty that means we can
return one as the base case as we
previously discussed
the other base case is if we reach the
end of string
s and that means we can't possibly match
the string t
anymore so we're going to return 0 in
that case last base case
is if this ij pair has already been
computed
in our cache if that's the case then we
can return
the value that is stored in our cache so
then we remember there's two cases for
the logic that we have to cover so if s
of i matches exactly t of j
then we know we're gonna be running
depth first search we're gonna be doing
it two different ways we're gonna be
looking at the remainder of string s
and the remainder of string t and we're
going to also be calling depth for
search
with the remainder of string s but the
entirety of string t so we're going to
be incrementing i
but not incrementing j in this case and
we're going to call both of these
and total up the result and then once
that has been totaled we can return it
but before we return it we want to make
sure that we cache it
so let's put it in the cache at position
i j
the else condition is basically the same
thing
as this except i'm gonna copy paste it
so except this portion right since these
characters don't match
we have to only shift our eye pointer we
still have to look for
a character that matches the character
at position j
and once either of these has been
computed then we can return whatever
value
we ended up storing in our cache and
this is the entirety of the depth first
search function pretty short because we
didn't have to pass in a lot of
variables into it because i defined this
function inside of another function that
just makes things easier for me
so now all we have to do is call it so
let's call debt for search
starting at 0 0 for both of the
beginning of the strings
and then we return the result so this is
going to be big o
n times m basically multiplying the
length of the strings together
time and memory complexity i hope that
this was helpful
if it was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully
see you pretty soon thanks for watching